và bây giờ mình có tốt lắm nhận mạnh, về công tác chính trị từ tưởng trong đảng, công tác xe dự đảng về chính trị từ tưởng trong giai đận mới,
cần tiếp tục lực trú trọng, tăng cường, tạo nên đảng với chắc về nâng cao bản lính, tính tiền phong, tính trên lấu và năng lực lãnh nhạo cần kiền của đảng.
Tổ mới thư đệ nghị cám bộ đảng viên trong toàn đảng, tiếp tục phán triệt sâu sắc, thực hiện thật nghiệm tục nhất bán bốn kiền đệnh từ về chính trị từ tưởng.
Đó là khiến đệnh gặp dụng và phát triển sáng tạo chúng ta mắt lên đến tưởng hủ chimêng, khiến đệnh mục tiêu đồng lập dân tộc và chúng ta sàng hội, khiến đệnh đường lối tổ mới của đảng, khiến đệnh cám về tóc tổ chức và hát đậu của đảng để xây dự bảo vệ vấn chắc tổ thúc Việt Nam sâu hủy á.
Cái gì vận dục mà phát triển sáng tạo chúng ta mắt lên đến từ tưởng hủ chimêng, tây là cơ sở để đảng tăng giữ vấn bản chất kết mạng, chúng ta cũng như người liết, cốt loại, đồng thời vận dục linh hoàn phát triển sáng tạo của tổ phy tự Việt Nam và yêu cầu của thay đạn.
Họ là kiến định mục tiêu đặc lập dân tộc của chúng hế sau hội, đây là sự đợi trọt mang tính lịch sử, là sự chỉ đó xin xuất là một tính chính kết mạng Việt Nam là một tiêu lý dự của đảng phát.
Chúng bất cứ hòn cạnh được kịch nào, cạnh trước khó khăn thách thức, cạnh phy dự bất cứ những niềm tiêm mặt linh và i chi đối với con đường đảng phát nhận lưỡ tà, nhận dân tà, đợi trọt.
Nó là kiến định đường đối đồn mới của đảng, tên lợi yêu cầu khích quan là quá trình kết mạng của tính quy lật.
Để không ngừng thức đại tiến bộ sòi giải phóng sức sản xuất khơi thông ngoại ngồi lực, nạn rặt không càn phát triển và nừng cao vý thế của đất đất.
Kết định tình thành đồn mới, đúng định hưởng đồn mới của mình tắc, đồn mới vý sự phát triển của đất đất vài phục của gia dân.
Nó là kiến định các mình tắc tổ chức quá đồng của đảng để xây dự và bảo vệ vương trắc tổ của vình ám sau ở chúng ta.
Nhà mò ràm, dự vương sự thông nhất với i chi hành động, dự vương kiến đoạn kỳ cương và hoài tròn hình đạo quan dế em của đảng.
Về mục tiêu tăng trưởng 2 con số, tổ mỹ thứ khẳng định này là nó hỏi khách quan từ yêu cầu phát triển đất nước trong dạ đạm mới và các bạn vừa lên của các bạn tổ.
Không chất nhận tăng trưởng thấp, phải kinh chi tự kiện mục tiêu tăng trưởng kinh để cao, bên vững tự chất.
Vì vậy, tổ mỹ thứ yêu cầu các mang bộ ngành địa phương, người dân, gần nhật, cân quan chệ sâu sắc bốn người tắc cốt lỗi hồm, tăng trưởng thực chất.
Không nên đổi chất lượng, tính bệnh vấn lấy tốt lộ tăng trưởng đơn thần. Cình định vấn tắc ở định kinh tế viên mục tiêu tăng trưởng tham phát và đam các tân đối lớn đây là điều kiện tiên quyết, chủ cột, quyết định khả năng gần hành liên hoạt, ăn quan và hiệu quả của phản bộ nên khi tế, tận dụng hiệu quả mọi người lực sản có, tập trung yêu tiên cho các dãng trong điểm và tụng đầy hợp tắc công tư để ra tăng hiệu quả đấu dư và nâng cao năng lực cảnh trành khúc ra.
Tăng trưởng kinh tế cao phải bảo đam phục u lợi ích, nâng cao đổi sống gật chất tình thần của những dần và cố bằng sản hội.
Không đến đổi chất lợp, tính bệnh vấn lấy tốt lộ tăng trưởng đơn thần. Tốt lộ tăng trưởng kinh tế, phải đi đôi, với chất lượng tăng trưởng, dự chế tăng năng xuất, các viên tố tổn hợp, nâng cao chất lượng sản phẩm, sức kính tranh cuo ra, của ra chỉ ra tăng thật chất.
Mối phẩm chăm tăng trưởng dí bì phải chữa được tìm hàm lượng chi thức của ra chỉ ra tăng cao hơn.
Đàm bảo tăng trưởng hôm nay không làm tổn hại, nền tạng phát triển của ngày mai không làm xí rạng của lực, bước vết thế tình lài của đất đất.
Ginh quyết lại bỏ tư dí trạy theo phình tích. Nếu chỉ trạy theo tốt bỏ, mặc xem nhẹ chất lợp tì tăng trưởng sẽ không quyền vấn và tức ra hãi phải trạy.
Chị cơ sở bún miếng tắc cơ lỗi, đặc trình khai một tư tăng trưởng hà còn số.
Phải được tiến hình một cách nhất quan, đồng bộ và kinh định với dử dụng chỉ đạo tập trung cao của chúngều, sử vừa hợp chạy dựa các bàn bộ ngành được thường và toàn bộ hiện hủ chí chi.
Pổ bị thư yêu cầu để tạo nốc lực của độ lực chúng ta chiển.
Chúng tôi không cần sớm sẽ dựng nghị quyết về mô hình phát triển đất nước trong gia đặt mới, dựa trên pho học, công nghệ đủ mời sáng tạo và chuyển đối số.
Để hội nghệ Trung Quốc là khoảng 187,
về phát vý thấy mạnh môi hình chính quyền địa xương 2 cấp,
tổ miết thương nhận mạnh,
môi hình chính quyền địa xương 2 cấp hiện nay
không chỉ là môi hình tổ chức hành chính mới
mà có lắp đứa khoảng 6 đợt thương mới,
nhằm bỏ tận nước trung dân để tổ chức hành bộ mại chính quyền cơ sở thống xuất,
bởi ngọn lực dược phân bộ hợp lý,
công nghệ và giữ liệu được sự dược quả,
phụ vụ người dân và gặp tốt hơn.
Vực liệu hành hoạt động,
môi hình chính quyền địa xương 2 cấp và được thực hiện
với tư dưới liệu hành hoạt động,
khoảng 179,
trong giúp quên máy mộng.
Không thể lấy một quên mẫu dưới nhất,
áp trong ngoại điều phương mọi đơn vị cơ sở
bởi điều kiện dân số dịnh tích tính chấp lâu thi,
nông thốt, mình nguy đồng bằng,
yêu cầu văn hoán quốc phẳng,
anh lình mức độ phát triển kinh tế sau
và khu lợt công việc của môi nơi rất khách nhau.
Nếu chỉnh khai mà cách cưng nhất,
rất dễ này xin của mấy công cạnh,
mấy ngay gấp cơ sở đi ngược lại,
nhưng tư tinh gọn hiệu lực kỳ quá,
mời chúng ta đã đặt ra.
Ui cùng phải lấy sự 2 lòng của mây dân và ra nghiệp là mức độ thật chấp
là tiêu chi quý cùng để đến giá thành công của môi hình chính quyền,
được quên 2 cấp.
Về công tác kìm chà giám sát,
kìm xóc quyền lực và đấu tranh phòng chống thầm miệu lắng phi,
yêu cơ tổ miếng tư tôn lắm để hệ.
Kìm chà giám sát, kìm xóc quyền lực,
đấu tranh phòng chống thầm miệu lắng phi,
yêu cơ tổ miếng tư t
xonte thầm.
và mọi vì cả bà đảm nguyên tất thông cộng cộng cộng cấm không quại lệ
nhưng đồng thời phải vãnh chiếc sâu sắc tính nhân văn thượng tôn thấp lần và mục tiêu khách chiến
trong đó hại tiếp lập và bản hành dụ quả các cơ trế bảo vệ cánh bộn năng đầu
sáng tạo, đăng nghĩ, giám làm, giám sử trích giợ bí lợi trông
phân định gió dành dưới dưới dưới dưới dưới dưới dưới dưới dưới dưới dưới dưới
dưới dưới dưới dưới dưới dưới dưới dưới dưới dưới
dưới dưới dưới dưới